welcome back okay it's time for our
super sized pop quiz yeah
all right nicole henkel you have been
selected now yesterday you won a
thousand dollars you can walk away with
your 1 000 today or you can give it back
to us right now and you can come back
tomorrow to play a super sized pop quiz
for the chance to win
5 000
i will come back tomorrow
yesterday
but
you gave it back
and you risked it all
yup you gave back the one thousand
dollars because we told you today you'd
have a chance at 5 000
so
you're back to zero but for every
question you answer correctly you'll win
one hundred dollars if you get a second
one you'll get two hundred dollars if
you get all three right you get
five thousand dollars right here
nicole are you ready i am ready you have
been on pins and needles you've been
waiting for this
all right i have two all right first
question how many times did marie osmond
marry her husband by the way i remarried
my first husband and so it's like
honeymoon all over again and uh but now
i'm i want to go back out on the road
too
that's right
that's exactly right okay second
question which shoe did we pick during
drew and a what shoe do you think would
be the most impressionable walking into
like an interview or something for the
fashion industry i say
the more fun the better i would do the
red
boot i'm all about the red boot red boot
the red boot that's right
that's 200
okay i'm sorry i just get too invested
it all comes down to this for five
thousand dollars how often
do dermatologists say that you should be
washing your pillowcase you're supposed
to wash your pillowcases every day every
day
do you mind sharing this story with us
nicole
um you're getting emotional and i was
wondering why since we've all been
sharing on this show together
because when kovit first hit and we had
to shut down i had to shut down my tax
business and i actually got
sick for seven weeks and i lost 17 000
and because of having to go virtual and
stuff i never was able to recoup it
so this means
so what this is
well then i have to throw in an extra
ten thousand dollars
[Applause]
you were everything that you oh my gosh
thank you nicole for sharing your story
thank you so
[Applause]
oh my much
well
well that was that was fun
um
i mean it this this
place this show has something really
wonderful about it so thank you for
choosing to spend your time with us that
is an honor
and that goes for everybody watching at
home and on the go
thank you so much and we hope that we
see you soon take this with you
[Music]